before you watch this video there is an
extended 3-hour version over at sargon
of akkad channel you can click it and go
there after watching this uncensored
this was not aired terrestrially you're
welcome
America and UK Jared comes and you know
smacks me when I'm not looking which is
what guys do I smack him back my wife
does I never would that is sexism now if
there is negative sexism and if you are
a good feminist you so glad to have this
next guest for those of you listening to
rest early on Wham or any of our
wonderful affiliates we will have a
bonus extended uncensored cut online
exclusively at ladder with credo comm
this gentleman he hails from the UK and
I've noticed a really large contingency
of people sort of not becoming more
conservative but becoming more open to
pro freedom ideas immensely popular you
can find them on YouTube sargon of a CAD
did I get that right sir pretty much
yeah pretty much
okay what's the much pretty much part
that I got wrong well I think it depends
on where you come from and how you
pronounce it I mean it's the name of an
ancient Mesopotamian Emperor right
transliterated into modern English I
mean the name is actually a Shahrukh nu
of a kdu or something yeah so Sargon of
Akkad is close enough all right there we
go well I'm glad to have you on the the
program you came to us through my lowly
Annapolis who people really liked and
you know it's funny like you said you
didn't really expect I guess to be
answer this terrestrially syndicated
show and I never really expected to be
kind of merging the worlds that I am so
we have these people who are really
popular online and then people who are
really popular with the terrestrial
audience and and they don't know about
the two separate worlds so um you sort
of would you say gamergate is what's
really given you this sort of rise to
notoriety would you say that's the
biggest sort of catalyst or no I I like
the use of the web nice variety it is it
is I was a little worried in calling you
I mean we've called a Imam Chaudhary and
I was more nervous about you yeah I been
them I'd been doing my youtube channel
for abouts probably about a year before
game again
about 20,000 subscribers and since then
I'm now on about 130,000 or so and
that's been about nine months so it's
probably really helped me yeah so that
wasn't the reason I got into it no I
mean it's pretty drastic now I will say
this obviously if we go to your channel
and we've talked about gamergate I don't
want to get too far off into the weeds
in the technicality a lot of people
won't understand it but um why do you
think that has been such a big driver
why do you think that's become so
important because a huge portion of your
content now is either centered around
gamergate or the social justice warrior
sort of topic I think initially I mean
I've always been the the main reason
that I got into doing my youtube channel
in the first place is because I've
become very very concerned with what I
see as major violations of the
principles of classical liberalism I I
find it very very disturbing some of the
some of the bizarre attitudes I've heard
coming out of the press coming on the
gaming press the mainstream press just
you know the the prevailing attitudes
are worrying they really disturbed me
there seems to be this remarkable amount
there are a lot of people who simply
don't see bias as a bad thing they think
objectivity is silly they think that's
collusion for the greater cause of
extreme progressivism it's just fine
they think that the presumption of guilt
is acceptable in certain conditions
right they they think oh all kinds of
frankly insane things that I I can't
countenance and gamergate is kind of
kind of a result of all of these things
these people don't seem to have any
scruples so they seem to have no problem
with colluding and attacking their
audience but for the you know to promote
their agenda and being corrupt and you
know openly corrupt oh these people left
a massive paper trail across Twitter the
whole places because they thought that
they were untouchable they didn't think
that anything was going to happen right
and so when you know well we talked
about that on this program a lot
obviously not just the gamergate thing
yeah but as sorry as a Yankee you know
Walter Cronkite Tom Brokaw Dan Rather
Brian Williams Larry
all people who at one time were thought
of as my got actual journalists and all
of them are just as guilty now to go to
one thing you said I wouldn't say to
disagreement
I think objectivity is a noble ideal I
think more noble is truth and I think
that pretty much any journalist even if
they try not to has some sort of a bias
and that's I mean I'm a comic so I was
always honest about it the issue the
issue is never really achieving
objectivity because obviously you can't
you know sure it you know the only way
you could do that has it for robots but
it's um the journey is verily ex machina
says we're going that way so careful now
and they can be very attractive by the
way not the only will be the future but
the important thing is the journey
rather than the destination it's
attempting to become objective that is
important because these people instead
of they have done exactly what I
consider to be the wrong thing to do
they've looked at the situation said
well you can never really be objective
so what's the point in trying even
though it's the attempts to be objective
that's important right it's um our
Stossel said that some excellence isn't
an act it's a habit right it's what you
do repeatedly and these people are
repeatedly biased solipsistic they they
don't care about reporting the facts as
relevance to the real world they care
about something they call the narrative
right which is a sequence of
cherry-picked events that they used to
justify their worldview and they quite
happily exclude items that frankly don't
you know fit this constructive narrative
right well you're actually sending a lot
like Andrew Breitbart right now he
talked about that for years and
everyone's fond of him and said he was a
hey have you ever have you actually I
mean you're in the UK and we as
Breitbart London now with Milo but if
you followed Andrews work at all uh no
not at all actually no it's well not I
watched one interview with him and he
seemed like a nice enough chap what's
funny girl everyone made him seem like
this radical extremist you know he was a
guy pro drug what pro drug pro
legalization of drugs totally couldn't
care in the social issues he was
pro-life from a scientific standpoint
and but he always talked about the media
narrative and he was the one who I guess
if you haven't followed him he was the
one who just demolished Anthony Weiner
found the Twitter pictures but what the
story a lot people don't know about that
so I gotta know I'll bring you back
right after this break is people accused
Andrew Breitbart
before he released those pictures of
lying and hacking Anthony Weiner's
Twitter the press knew that Anthony
Weiner had done something and they
decided to go after Andrew again because
it's set the narrative so it forced his
hand literally to release the space
odyssey' pecker shot that we then saw in
the media bring you right back after
this ladder with Grutter sargon of akkad
some name I can't pronounce
Sargon you are back sir and I will give
you the floor but I think that you would
probably find a lot of commonality with
with someone like Andrew Breitbart
and I say that as a compliment I know
some people would hear that and take it
as an insult the guy really understood
media bias and in media narrative better
than anyone I've ever I've watched a few
in fuse with Ben Shapiro who says that
he was a good friend of Andrew Breitbart
yeah and he I mean the people who have
known him that I've seen speak about him
speak very very highly of him
so that's that's to his credit yeah I
knew I was pretty good for Andrew and um
you know I never worked I never worked
for him on a professional level I was
one of the first writers ever at his
site when it was big Hollywood in but I
was never on a pay scale so we had a bit
of a different relationship and um he
loved my wife loved my wife he would
always talk about how if you've seen my
wife she's way out of my league sorry
we're getting off topic so I haven't
seen your wife it's um
yes the the problem of the media is that
they honestly there are a lot of there
are many different problems that are all
coalescing into one gigantic hideous
monster the first we have looks like a
feminist to continue
yeah it's but it's not feminism is just
one aspect of it the problem in the
monster would physically resemble a
feminist it was just a short jail no
sorry yeah absolutely feminine feminism
is definitely an aspect of it I mean
they they would call it in section ality
so it's all all manner of radical
progressive opinions that have become
mainstream that's the problem right are
not fringe anymore they've become
mainstream but the the the an issue
the main problem is that the right you
got the right wing and I just for anyone
this thing I'm not right wing I i'm
center-left the right wing has been
completely defeated you guys have lost
the public debate and it's it's really
disheartening to see but you kind of
brought it on yourselves I mean not you
personally but they say it's a bit of a
dick comment but I understand when it's
general I was like come on I'm having
you on the show
don't blame me for the failures of the
right wing but that I don't assuming you
know I know I'm joking I'm doing I know
but you guys are gonna start being
honest with yourselves you know and Ben
Shapiro I can't recommend him highly
enough he understands where you guys
have gone wrong and I recommend anyone
who's curious check him out um but
basically you guys have you guys were
great counts weights to the extreme left
and you failed frankly it's not not
anything personal I'm see but it's so I
would say we've certainly failed
politically obviously recently and there
are some issues where culturally we
failed but I think that this is a great
example where you don't realize it as
you say some of these things you are not
center-left if you were to come to the
United States you would be considered a
right-wing extremist just by what you're
expressing right well that's the problem
that's the problem it doesn't matter
what I would be considered right because
it's nice to take a political compass
test which I have obviously done I'm
left the issue is that the progressive
left is so far to the left anyone who is
even slightly more right than them is
far right in their opinion right but
basically a lot of the people who
subscribe to my channel are people who
are left-wing but not extreme
progressives and what we are effectively
seeing is a civil war within the left
and this was really I did a video about
this because it really really
highlighted the issue there was a point
where the radical feminists declared
chivalry to be sexist now you can
imagine that there were quite a few
left-wing you know gentlemen who
considered themselves to be rather
feminist you know they were they were in
they were concerned about women's rights
and equal pay and all this sort of thing
and I know Ventura Janis wimps who are
cooking in sweats when they come on no I
know I'm sure I'm joking but listen I
mean there are radical ones but I'm
talking about the moderate ones who you
know they fall here you know I here's
the one thing I would say that before we
get off that true I would say there's
nothing moderate about wanting equal pay
there's nothing moderate about saying
women should have the right to vote
about equal rights there's nothing
moderate about that but we have it so
what is considered extreme is for me to
say it's not an issue anymore that needs
to be discussed because you have those
things so I understand what you're
saying but I think you relinquish a
little bit of territory by even
considering that moderate because the
left already cuz there's that that's not
what I was considering moderate that
okay I was really speaking I was really
speaking to what they consider rightly
more not rather than my own opinion is
there is no gender pay gap what it is is
an earnings gap right women choose
careers that pay less and they work less
and therefore in total they earn less
it's common sense um but yes so
basically a large portion of a left mean
you could see this in the Daily
Telegraph in the UK on literally in
subsequent days in the same newspaper
you had editorials
from various different staff members
either lionizing or castigating these
radical feminists who declared chivalry
to be sexist
right and you could see the contrast
they're like no it's not sexist for me
to you know what to hold a door open for
a woman that's me being a gentleman you
know but then you have the other cycling
yeah but that in itself is just
benevolent sexism it's it's still sexism
and so this is where the sort of radical
left are really starting to lose people
and what basically and that's our
language matters because you know I
inherently if you want to get down in
the definition it is sexism and that you
are treating someone differently because
of their sex but like I've always said
I've said this on the show many times I
don't know how many people in your
channel have seen it
III told a friend of mine I told my wife
I said listen it is sexism
that has me treating you so much better
than I treat my video producer Jared if
Jared comes and you know smacks me when
I'm not looking which is what guys do I
smack him back my wife does it I never
would that is sexism
now if there is negative sexism and if
you were a good feminist you'd well
exactly and I'm not by the way you
should I'm not saying you should hit
women but the point is um it is it says
that protects women I mean if you get in
YouTube right now benevolent sexism
and I'm okay with that term
benevolent sexism at least it starts
with benevolent this is the thing
ultimately the the path of reasoning
they've gone down it does lead to the
point where you realize that any
treatment of women for being even
slightly different which they obviously
are different how do you a form of
sexism and it's too extreme for almost
you know everyone except the extreme
Perez's but the problem is this sort of
extreme progressivism is what's being
pumped out of universities now
university students are being frankly I
would say indoctrinated into this this
this is the thing you guys seem to have
lost not only the media battle but the
academic battle and mainly this comes
because you guys don't have any
communications courses you'd in
communications courses what they are
teaching students these days are the
tricks of Edward Bernays and Saul
Alinsky and you've probably got some
viewers whose ears have perked up at
those two names already
well Andrew Bret bro was the one who
brought Saul Alinsky to the foreground
and drew that sort of connection with
him in radical leftists like President
Obama and the thing is what's
interesting about Olinsky is um he he
was a leftist obviously and he never he
wasn't the full-on Marxist but his his
book rules for radicals isn't a partisan
text no it's it's a lot he describes it
as the counter points to Machiavelli's
The Prince so its amounts where
Machiavelli's The Prince is the book to
help the haves keep what they have the
rules for radicals is to help they have
not take what they have so it's it's not
a partisan book so people in the right
one can read it but the thing is it's
more of an instruction manual than
anything it is but this this goes back
to this with Edward Bernays these these
techniques are bad techniques right I
personally find them immoral you know I
don't think that you should propagandize
people I don't think that you should
manipulate and lie and deliberately
politicized issues that aren't political
and like elinsky said accused them of
doing what you yourself are doing
exactly open to their own standards
because they're obviously unrealistic
but you would never realistically expect
someone to be able to maintain their
highest standard everyone's human
everyone has failures sure and yet to
demand it you can't really go against it
without looking
like a villain so it's well and there
there's really that's there's a pivotal
issue there and that's why the right has
sort of lost culturally again because
yeah they've conceded territory not only
media entertainment academia and and the
narrative is set where basically it'd be
like someone watching someone going for
a high jump you know leftists or sitting
there watching from the stands going you
didn't hit the perfect Fosbury flop
there and they laugh it but they don't
even attempt it so you get zero right
you don't just you don't get a 5 you get
a 0 you get a 0 you get a B in your back
in fact you might get exact you might
you may even get a native saying that
you're actually trying to damage the
sport of high diving you know the these
the the problem is that the left have
spent decades in academia solidifying
their position and with all sorts of
complex rationales that they have
sociological definitions for things for
example racism is not nearly being
prejudiced against someone based on
their skin color or their race that
that's not what racism means to the
extreme progressive sociological
definition of word what they use its
mean is a system of or interlocking sort
of system of power structures so in
their minds if you're not someone who is
benefiting from a power hierarchy you
can't be racist so in their minds white
people are the only people who can be
racist because if you look at say
politicians in the US or in the UK any
European country then predominately
white and they preyed on male because
what else don't like that you lumped the
u.s. in with European countries we are
not of your ilk sir well you know I'm
Canadian right we still have your silly
queen and her money continued you know I
didn't hear no man can tell very clearly
from me I had it beaten out of me I'm
french-canadian so my mom is actually my
mom is actually French which if you want
to talk racism we've talked about this
before yeah this interviews over sorry
Ian the French from Paris French from
France don't like there's no one left to
hate everyone hates the French and so
once you get down to French like well
who's the other sect of French people
and the people from pairs like we we had
the french-canadian and then the French
and so we added up people from Paris and
there's no one left so I get it I get
continue sorry yes so basically in in
Western countries the people who
predominance of power in say
corporations and governments are white
men and you know that's to be expected
they're the majority over a population
of the working population are white men
right so you are going to end up with
majority white men in positions of power
and so the the sociological definition
of these things that racism the sexism
they they have taken all of this into
account and decided that what this is
and I'm going to quote directly they
call it a white supremacist capitalist
patriarchy and so they think that if you
aren't a white man then you cannot be
racist or sexist which enables them to
go and be as hateful as they'd like to
white men in fact being a white man is a
pejorative term in these circles being
right-wing is a pejorative term in these
circles they will they will call you
right wing as an insult this is how bad
your names are this is you know I hate
to be the bearer of bad news and I get
kind of annoyed by it because I'm not
right-wing but I'm on extreme rightist
if if you'd listen to them you know and
I think you're reasonable and I think
there was a point where were people who
were right-wing and listen I think I
have a lot of family members and
probably when I was a young teenager was
guilty of this where because of the
religious influence and I am I'm full
disclosure I still I'm a Christian I
think a lot of people didn't have to
rationalize their arguments anytime you
get into an echo chamber so I think one
could have argued yeah the right wing
seemed like they were fixated on certain
points and weren't open to reason I
think that's flopped where now you've
got the left and like you said they have
their very important narrative that they
will protect at all costs through
Alinsky tactics you were singing my song
babe
and now they're the ones who are closed
off to reason
alright so wrap this up real quick well
we'll have to go to a break and then
bring you on for the online segment but
where can people best find you they can
type in tsagaan of a CAD into Google and
my name actually comes up first so my
youtube channel would be the first link
again look at him being all coy he has
SEO operator than the same
first but I just fell into it
sargon of akkad we will keep you for the
online segment if you're listening to
rest really louder with credit calm stay
tuned if you like this be sure to
subscribe by clicking my general face in
this box or listen again to the extended
version of the interview with Sargon
over at his channel it's three whole
hours right below that we have an
interview with my Logan appleís who is
also a fantastic interview and happens
to be really gay